have y'all met Selena before first time
okay you might she might have been the
one stalking in a comic-con or whatever
it's called there's all these cons I
don't know I need to go to them so y'all
were called the rolling stones of true
crime that's a pretty sexy title y'all
know everybody I mean if you're if
you're rolling stones of true crime that
means everyone watches you I mean I've
been a listener for a long time and that
just doesn't happen okay
it's I mean I certainly didn't see this
coming when we started doing true crime
stories about I don't know close to a
little more than ten years ago I didn't
want to do it I wasn't interested
I usually usually when you're covering
cops well we've been here twenty found
it we've been here we've been a Dateline
25 years each yeah Wow you must like it
so I mean you're a big fan right yeah
okay do you have any questions okay
what's the craziest story that you can
remember oh gosh it just means there
been so many the one you're on now yeah
sure that you know the missing kids in
Idaho the ones the Hawaii connection
Arizona and all of it
so we're chasing around trying to I know
there's missing kids in Idaho and Hawaii
what did you say I don't know this oh
you don't know this tell me this right
okay well they disappeared in September
the authorities been trying to get the
mother of those children and her new
husband to reveal their where they are
and if they will just reveal it all this
might go away but there's also the
question of the new husband's ex-wife
who mysteriously passed away though she
was very healthy the new wife's
ex-husband whose brother shot her but
then later on her brother mysteriously
died there's this trail of death that is
following these people around the
country I can't even keep up with what
you just said no no I was like training
a to train be like what there's so many
crazy things complicated story he
compressed that into about two hours a
few weeks ago and
pretty hard to do then it was I do you
all ever have like nightmares from all
the things that you see how he's
wonderful like investigators or cops our
journalistic people doing this like
that's why I had to kind of check out
for a bit because I started freaking out
thinking everyone was gonna kill me
and I'd lock my doors all the time I
literally am the friend my assistant and
my nanny everybody will tell you I make
everyone text me when they're home and
they've checked their house this is a
real thing
like did you y'all don't get effective
oh that's not a bad idea
absolutely yes but you don't get you
don't get fazed by it like you don't
know
in fact the crime rate has gone down
it's like there aren't as many murders
as they used to be bombed dang it wish
there could be more crime you you know
you do see some terrible things in this
job you also see some stories of
tremendous strength and redemption and
people who struggle against really
terrible things that have happened to
them and end up doing things that they
wouldn't have thought possible so you
see families which are suffering and
they managed to come through and that's
one of the inspirational things about
this and the other is that you know this
show is really sort of about the best in
law enforcement it's true yeah I'm
telling you they the the people who
solve crimes in this country even though
sometimes they get a bad reputation once
in a while are overall the most
committed marvelous people you get it
over to me and especially homicide
detectives yeah
subscribe to my channel subscribe to my
channel subscribe to my channel
subscribe to my channel please don't
make me keep going